a portion of Robert Muller's final
report on the Russia investigation will
go public in 48 hours the Justice
Department plans to release parts of the
nearly 400 page report on Thursday
morning after removing material as
required by law so far we have only seen
the Attorney General's four page summary
of the report and scattered sentences
from it Democrats want to see the entire
report without redactions Paula Reid has
covered the Muller investigation since
it began she's at the White House Paula
how is the Trump administration
preparing for this partial release of
the Malheur investigation well John the
president's attorneys are not waiting
until Thursday Rudy Giuliani tells CBS
news that he's working on a counter
report that he plans to release after
this redacted Muller material comes out
the president's legal team is quote
confident that any politically damaging
evidence that comes out can be deflected
by pointing to the legal conclusions
that the Special Counsel found no
collusion and the Attorney General
cleared the President on this question
of obstruction so far the only sign of
anxiety coming out of the White House is
from the president's Twitter account
just moments after it was announced this
is coming Thursday the president Rhee
upped his attacks on the special counsel
calling the investigators Trump haters
so Paula have they seen the report
because how do you create a rebuttal for
a report you haven't seen and what kind
of a fight do you think will happen once
this report partial report comes out Don
this will be a historic legal fight
Democrats have already said they intend
to subpoena any evidence that is
redacted they may even subpoena special
counsel robert muller and i've spoken to
sources close to muller who confirmed he
would cooperate the Attorney General has
even volunteered to come testify before
Capitol Hill at this point there is no
indication that the president's
attorneys have seen this report at all
likely this redacted the version that
they're working on this counter report
to their redacted material is mostly
based on publicly available information
and let to fill in a few blanks once
they get the redacted report all right
Paula thank you we'll be sorting through
what's actually in the report and what
people claim is in the report and what's
in the summary got to keep the eye on
the ball here that's right in CBS News
we will stick to reporting the facts
just the finest and I can't wait to see
it whatever it is